تسمعي الموسيقى بالشغل
ما تقدرين العمل هلا طيب بالبيت
تسمعين موسيقى قبل النوم لا
بس عادي وانا بقرا وانا بشتغل
اغاني لكن الموسيقى شو اسمه وقت النوم حلو
هي موسيقى قد تساعدك على النوم موسيقى
اخرى بايقاعات اسرع قد تحفزك على ممارسه
الرياضه في بعض الحالات الموسيقى تقلل
مشاعر القلق وتنجح بذلك اكثر من الادويه
الفعل بين الموسيقى
وتاتي كثير من الدراسات سواء كانت محفزه
ام مشتته لكن هل يمكن ان تساعدنا الموسيقى
على زياده انتاجيتنا في العمل العلم ينحاز
لهذه الفرضيه لكن يحدد موسيقى معينه طبقا
لطبيعه كل مهمه الدراسات تقول ان مهام
العمل المعقده مثلا تحتاج لموسيقى فقط
الات تعزف في الخلفيه ولكن دون كلمات وفي
هذه الحاله يرشح الباحثون الموسيقى
الكلاسيكيه على كل حال هناك اشياء يجب
مراعاتها عند التفكير قبل تشغيل الموسيقى
اثناء العمل هذه الاشياء راح نتعرف عليها
مع لميس ابراهيم
لميس شنو هي الاشياء في
كثير
وفقا للعلم يجب مراعاه بعض الاشياء قبل
تشغيل الموسيقى لتعزيز الانتاجيه اولها
تحديد موسيقى مناسبه لكل مهمه حتى لا
تستنزف طاقتك العقليه اولها اعداد قائمه
من الموسيقى لاستخدامها اثناء المهام
الممله وهنا ينصح المختصون بموسيقى مبهجه
بايقاع سريع واغاني البوب بشكل خاص
الموسيقى الكلاسيكيه مرشحه دائما في مختلف
الابحاث وهناك نظريه علميه يطلق عليها
تاثير موثاره تقول ان الاستماع الى موسيقى
مفيد لتعزيز نشاط الدماغ ورفع معدل الذكاء
المكاني الموسيقى التصويريه للافلام خاصه
الافلام المنحنيه واعمال دراما الحروب
التاريخيه تاخذك في رحله تشعر معها وكانك
تغير العالم وبالتالي من المحتمل ان تزيد
من انتاجيتك في النهايه عند تعلم شيء جديد
او الدخول في مشروع معقد بالعمل يفضل
حينها تجنب الاستماع الى الموسيقى في
البدايه بشكل عام لا ينصح بالاستماع الى
الموسيقى طوال ذلك اليوم
[موسيقى]
ينضم الينا في الاستديو الطبيب النفسي
ومؤسس شركه عرب ثيرابي الصحه النفسيه
الدكتور طارق الدلبح دكتور صباح الخير
صباح النور يعني خليني اسال سؤال اليوم
حتى ما ادري راح اخذك شوي بعيد حتى في
الزار
وربما بعض الاشياء هذه الايقاع جزء رئيسي
من هذه العمليه بانه يؤثر في الوجدان
الداخلي على الانسان وعلى عقليته ويبعث
الى عوالم اخرى صحيح الموسيقى اليوم تناسب
اشخاص وما تناسب اشخاص ثانيين
هلا حاليا احنا لازم نرجع لشويه مبادئ
اساسيه يا اخي نحكي لو بدنا نطلع على
النمو الانسان في في داخل البطن امه اول
صوت احنا بنسمعه هو صوت انسيابي هو صوت
الدم بيجري بالشرايين والاورده وصوت القلب
وصوت الرئه
وهاي هي اللي بتخلينا احنا جميعا كبشر
يعني بتعمل الاساس للاصوات اللي بالنسبه
مريحه او غير مريحه
هلا طبعا تفاعل كل شخص كل فرد بس يصير
بالغ مع الموسيقى تختلف يعني بناء على
عوامل اخرى زي الجينات زي التربيه زي هو
ايش تعلم زي ايش كان يسمعوا وهو صغير وايش
العلاقه علاقه الاصوات اللي كان يسمعو
الموسيقى اللي يسمعها
بالمشاعر اللي كان يحسها اثناء سماع خصوصا
في طفولته يعني موضوع نفسي بحت ما له
علاقه بافرازات هرمونات معينه مثل
الدوبامين او غيره في الدماغ لما نسمع نوع
معين من الموسيقى هذا مش مئه بالمئه لانه
الكيمياء والدوبامين والسيراتونين هي جزء
من جزء اساسي من الحاله النفسيه اللي احنا
بنعيشها
فالمشاعر اللي احنا بنحسها هي عباره عن
مجموعه هي بسموها المجموعه من العوامل من
العوامل بيولوجيه منها عوامل نفسيه منها
عوامل سلوكيه منها عوامل تربويه بتاثر
علينا والموسيقى هي عباره عن يعني حبه
بازل جوه هاي المجموعه كامله يعني دكتور
يعني خلينا نتفق على شيء انه كل شيء في
عالمنا هو صوت ايقاع رذم معين احنا قاعد
نمشي عليه في كلامنا هناك صوت وايقاع والى
اخره لكن في يوم من الايام انا يمكن قلت
لزوجتي وثاني يوم عندها مقابله قلت لها
تعالي يا سمعه موسيقى هادئه تريحين تنامين
وتروحين نشيطه
توترت وانعكس هذا الامر سلبي عليها رغم ان
هذا الامر يسعدني اني انام وانا مرتاح بل
يمكن اذهب الى النوم العميق ليش هلا
بيختلف كامره بيختلف بين شخص لشخص وبرضو
بيختلف بين الفئات العمريه يعني مثلا هلا
ايش الموسيقى الموسيقى بالعاده هي ايقاع
وزمن بشكل خلينا نحكي ونبسط جدا
احنا بنشوف انه مثلا عند الاطفال الاطفال
كثير بحبوا الموسيقى الايقاعيه المتكرره
اللي نوعا ما متوقع
بالضبط
يمكن كل الناس تكمل
وهذا مثلا بفئات عمريه مختلفه مثلا عند
الكبار بيحبوا اكثر
الموسيقى اللي هي تقسيم مثلا اللي ما فيها
عرب بنحب الموسيقى الحزينه
اللي فيها سلطنه
بس بس ممكن نقول انه
قطع المقطوعات الموسيقيه اللي بدون كلمات
بتكون اسهل
لنستخدمها في اذا كنا عم نعمل اي شي بده
تركيز احسن من اغاني فيها كلمات هو هو
بيختلف يعني الموسيقى اللي بتساعد على
التركيز هي بالعاده بتكون الفرق بين
النوتات ما بيكون فرق عالي يعني سمعنا هلا
حاليا مقطوعه مقطوعه موسيقيه
كلاسيكيه فيها قفزات عاليه بين النوتات صح
بكون مثلا بين اللا اللي فوق وبعدين بينزل
على الليدول اللي تحت
فممكن النوتات تعمل قفزه على اكتاف كامل
مئه بالمئه
انه في تكرار ويعني الفرق بين المقطوعه
الاولى المقطوعه التاني بيكون جدا وبعدين
برجع بطلع برجع لاول بعدين يعني بيكون
نوعا ما برضو في توقع دكتور الان عندنا
موعد
لعبه وتجربه اعددنا بعض المقاطع الموسيقيه
لكل منها لون مختلف لكنها اثبتت نجاح في
تعزيز الانتاجيه عندك كثير من الموظفين
اثناء العمل المطلوب ان زملائنا يقيمون
اذا كان من المحتمل نختار موسيقى تحفز
معدل انتاجيتهم ام لا بدنا منهم طبعا اذا
عجبتكم او كانت محفزات ترفعوا اصبعكم هيك
او العكس
سمعونا
[موسيقى]
فوق ولا تحت
يلا اللي بعدها
للعمل احنا قاعدين نقول
علاء
[موسيقى]
سياسي
اختلفوا اذا
ولاء قالت لا علاء قال لا شدان قالت يمكن
انا شايفه يمكن اول اول قط مقطوعه موسيقيه
هي ازبطشي
ولا لا علاء
شدان اتفقوا على انه لا مع انه بحر اعتقد
ما هو على حسب هذا الموضوع لشو يا عادل
لانه يعني بس خلينا نقول لزملائنا علاء
ولاء وشهدان شكرا جزيلا انكم مفصولين ان
شاء الله
يعني كل شخص عنده ذوق مختلف في الموضوع
يمكن اول اول اغنيه انا بتفق بانه فعلا
بتحفز على التركيز او مقطوعه الباقي كله
لا بالعكس في منهم ثنتين الاصوات الموج
واصوات الهواء بتحفز على النوم هلا يمكن
التاني اللي هم الثاني والاخيره هم اقرب
اصوات لصوت الدم جوا جوا الشرايين اللي
كنا نسمع له علاقه يعني
هل معنى ذلك نحن نستخدم شيء يحتاج تركيز
ذهني موسيقى ما تنفع لا تنفع لناس وفي ناس
ما بتنفع لكل حدا للتركيز مثلا موسيقى
الموج هاي اكثر الاسترخاء لانه بتذكرنا
واحنا اطفال ايش كنا نسمع في اكثر مرحله
بتنعس شكرا جزيلا للطبيب النفسي ومؤسس
شركه عرب ثيرابي للصحه النفسيه الدكتور
طارق شكرا شكرا
لمتابعتي المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقي والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات